la situación sigue grave en brasil donde
las últimas 24 horas se registraron dos
mil 648 muertes y hoy la fiocruz la
fundación oswaldo cruz indicó que el
país de dimensiones continentales vive
su peor crisis hospitalaria y sanitaria
de su historia 25 de los 27 estados
federados tienen una ocupación de las
camas de hospitalaria superior al 80 por
ciento siendo que de ellos 15 ya
superaron el 90 por ciento los médicos
advierten de que a partir de este
momento los brasileños podrían fallecer
por causas evitables como un infarto o
una apendicitis por la simple razón de
que no hay camas no hay médicos y no hay
nada en ese momento los hospitales están
abarrotados y mientras hoy supimos que
en el estado de san pablo el más
afectado del país 12 ciudades han
decretado en lockdown total y en
prácticamente todos los 27 estados se
han ido introduciendo en los últimos
días medidas de resto
el movimiento de los ciudadanos
precisamente para intentar reducir las
aglomeraciones algo que sin embargo no
se está pudiendo hacer porque hay mucho
trabajo precario en este país y muchas
personas que necesitan salir todos los
días para seguir trabajando mientras hoy
ha salido una nueva encuesta que muestra
que la popularidad de jair bolsonaro del
presidente del país está en horas bajas
el 56% de los brasileños creen que
evolucionaron sin capaz de liderar el
país en medio de la pandemia es su peor
dato hasta ahora y bolsonaro es
consciente que si no consigue estancar
las muertes y vacunar a su población de
212 millones de personas la reelección
de 2022 va a ser cada vez más difícil